avec nous Yann roche président de
l'Observatoire de géopolitique de la
chair Raoul d'enduran et professeur au
Département de géographie de l'UQAM
bonsoir
donc la plaignante qui est derrière les
deux plaintes sont à l'origine des
enquêtes de l'homme modusman c'est une
coalition de 28 organismes de défense
des droits humains et leurs allégations
ont le mentionné dans un reportage sont
assez bien documentés est-ce que ce
qu'on reproche à Naiki et diagnostics ça
vous semble plausible
je pense que c'est plus que plausible ça
fait déjà un bon bouton que beaucoup
d'observateurs extérieurs d'observateurs
qui sont neutres
mentionnent que il y a des problèmes
très très sérieux au Cynthia et il y a
juste le gouvernement chinois et
certaines personnes qui sont proches de
ce gouvernement qui sont qui sont contre
les allégations qui sont qui sont faites
à ce niveau là
c'est particulier parce que les
entreprises montrent du doigt
aujourd'hui il y en a une dans le
textile l'autre dans le secteur aurifère
mais c'est ce sont deux secteurs qui ont
été montré du doigt déjà ces dernières
années concernant le travail forcé des
Ouigours qu'est-ce qu'on sait au juste
du traitement qui est fait à cette
minorité ethnique de Chine et sur ces
industries qui sont impliquées
ce qu'il faut déjà préciser c'est qu'une
des compagnies c'est quand même naïki
Canada puis on va en parler peut-être
sans doute tout à l'heure c'était aussi
naïki c'est la maison mère qui a répondu
à mon but semaine pour essayer de
contrer les allégations et d'ailleurs
c'est elle qui s'est comporté de manière
par cœur moi arrogante naïki Canada
s'est caché derrière elle ce que l'on
sait c'est que rappelez-vous que ça a
commencé déjà depuis un certain nombre
d'années on avait
identifié la création de centre de de ce
qui semblait des carrément des camps de
concentrations que la Chine au Cynthia
que la Chine a d'abord nié que disons
qu'elle existait absolument pas puis
finalement quand l'épreuve sont
accumulées ils ont dit que c'était
simplement des camps de rééducation
politique pour faire des des wego des
bons citoyens des bons citoyens et puis
maintenant on s'est rendu compte que
c'est devenu un endroit où on les aide
ou du moins on les forme pour devenir
des des travailleurs disons obligatoires
et ça c'est c'est quelque chose que l'on
sait depuis un certain temps il n'y a
pas de il y a pas de contestation réelle
on vous disiez tant dans le cas de Niki
mais dans une ne pas faire beaucoup de
collaboration on a les deux entreprises
disent on n'a pas de contrôle sur la
situation on a rompu nos liens
d'affaires avec les sous-traitants en
question est-ce que ça vous étonne cette
position
pas du tout mais de toute manière je
pense qu'on pourrait aussi mentionner le
fait que
l'embutsman le bureau de ton busman dans
le reportage on disait que ça a été créé
en 2019 c'est assez récent les gens sont
plus ou moins au courant et on a dit que
leur il n'est pas vraiment de moyens
pour pour faire respecter un petit peu
leur leur position donc on sent
clairement que les deux compagnons en
question sont pas du tout intéressés
parce qu'ils ont pas peur et puis ils
ont la sensation que ils connaissent pas
déjà dans un premier temps le bureau de
nombusman et ils ont clairement aucun
respect mais puisque les pouvoirs du
bureau de l'embourdissement sont limités
qu'est-ce qu'on peut attendre de son
travail est-ce qu'on peut avoir vraiment
des réponses satisfaisantes
je pense que ça va être un peu différent
dans les entre les deux cas ce qui a été
mentionné c'est qu'une des une des
réponses c'est clairement une question
de pression qui peuvent être effectuées
sur les compagnies en ce qui concerne en
ce qui concerne Micky qui a déjà depuis
un certain temps été identifié comme
problématique et l'accompagner maire des
gens ça fait déjà plusieurs années
qu'elle est considérée comme ayant des
problèmes à ce niveau-là c'est les
consommateurs qui peuvent avoir un
impact en ce qui concerne les minières
c'est un peu différent et beaucoup plus
difficile de faire pression sur eux et
l'embusman avait mentionné justement
qu'en l'absence de pouvoir dont elle
disposait même si elle continue à
essayer d'en demander auprès du
gouvernement Trudeau c'est vraiment en
essayant de mettre la lumière sur ce qui
se passe et essayer de faire intervenir
les la consommation les gens qui peuvent
consommer et donc presser sur les
compagnies qu'on peut faire quelque
chose mais sur la minière c'est beaucoup
plus difficile et la manière dont elle
réagi montrent très clairement qu'elle
n'a pas peur je vais déjà un petit peu
mention donc 13 plaintes deux enquêtes
aujourd'hui donc 11 autres plaintes qui
sont à l'étude en ce moment il y en a
une qui concerne le droit d'association
au Honduras on sait que certains
organismes montent d'autres dossiers sur
des milliards canadiennes en Amérique
latine des entreprises au Bangladesh
aussi est-ce que ça prendrait plus de
mécanismes de surveillance des
entreprises canadiennes à l'oeuvre à
l'étranger selon vous
bien sûr mais on pourrait poser la
question et je pense que plusieurs
compagnies ont sans doute déjà du
soulever au moins dans les coulisses
sont dû en parler au gouvernement en
disant pourquoi nous on devrait avoir un
comportement irréprochable sachant que
la concurrence elle se gêne sans doute
pas alors que les compagnies canadiennes
soient irréprochables c'est bien tant
mieux et puis on est tous d'accord mais
elles vont se retrouver à être disons en
concurrence avec d'autres compagnies
dont les gouvernements seront peut-être
moins exigeants à ce niveau là et c'est
quelque chose qui va sans doute
ressortir un moment ou un autre oui il
faut faire quelque chose mais il
faudrait tout le monde le fasse que soit
une solution qui soit pas uniquement
canadienne qui s'applique à l'échelle à
l'échelle internationale
et le déroulement de ses enquêtes Yann
roche vous êtes président de
l'Observatoire de géol politiques de la
chair Raoul d'endurance professeur au
Département de géographie de l'UQAM
merci beaucoup
Merci à VOUS bonne soirée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]